just max out everything whenever
creating a character just maximize
everything done this is my actual hi yes
we're back with blade and sorcery hello
it's me you look good I look a little
concerned but I feel good I'm excited to
finally be playing some more let me just
cut my beard it doesn't work this game
is one of my favorite games in VR it's
hilarious let's go and kill it more kill
it in so now they have a couple new
levels that I haven't played so let's
try that out how about this the canyon
everyone traveled yes well it's a canyon
it's such a beautiful day everything is
okay okey-dokey flip flop flip flop flip
flop I don't know where I have my
weapons oh god where are all the weapons
the bad people coming Can I grab a hold
of this I got it oh I can't climb the
rope telling me come come come my god
this is so weird
come follow me I know you're afraid
come
what
I'm gonna grab him
I guess I'll have to use my specialty oh
I got it
it's mine I took it from him
come back here right away are you
kidding me
that's gotta be more oh oh
you decide to die he's crazy yeah yes no
you're not running you're not running
get his knees get his knees
you're not running you cannot run from
me all right ha ha ha bad boy bad boy
he's been a bad boy hey hey hey don't
come oh don't come near or your friends
will die
don't come near don't come near or you
stab your friend
Hey I was busy Oh
[Music]
dissect haystack yes ah give me the
sword
Oh oh god I need a store they keep
running away from me stop I will never
hurt the woman there will be articles I
am done with this Barros hey to you
barrels Thank You Barrow oh god please
stop don't hurt me
know what you can woman cannot fight
everyone knows wow that's freaking my
ball stop ever
yeah you can't show this to Jesus Christ
come come come come oh I dropped sword
come come I will not do anything I swear
I swear I'm innocent Swedish person I
will not do anything okay you are epic
don't be afraid oh you're coming you
fell for all this trick I have secret
agar drop this don't be afraid
[Music]
live or your friend gets by buying we
have a deal
subscribe to my channel or a friend goes
bye-bye
stop complaining let's get her knees
this way she can't run oh oh no sorry oh
this is so fun
why is being the worst person the most
epic time oh they come from there okay
please please mister I will not hurt you
I have no weapon I have no weapon makes
I get their fingers get the fingers get
the finger staffs right and then you get
the nice Nick's
next haha you will not roll for me
you're allowed to run from oh my god
he's trying to he's doing it you can do
it I believe oh no sorry let me pull it
out this is pathetic I can't hurt I
Swedish stance oh god what happened to
your face
sorry about that stop alright oh my god
stop the tracking oh god I'm dying no
one runs for jeribai no one runs let's
cut them off great thank you very much
I'm a slightly dying all right how do I
heal again nervously you can heal here's
the weapons I didn't see them
okay now I feel bad look at that it's
like a oh my god yes alright let's try
that again
oh my god I'm like the villain in
Allegan I'm falling over all this stupid
cable stinky cables what a my staff go I
don't have time
chip-chop
go back to an email and go back to bald
land jump go back to beard land
hey I'm busy
go back to door land yes yes yes huh
yeah yeah too powerful for you is it
lick it legit
jaesik he said to my child I don't wanna
listen look he has three legs
beautiful you're such realities make
sure they're dead
confirm kill my beautiful child we will
rule these lanes
I run please enlarge stop hurted oh he's
trying to escape my beautiful child
you don't understand the paradox of a
peace do you need war oh my god just how
do I return
oh it resets the legs my leg is gone
honey I don't need to make a new one
I just need the Nick make anyone all
right we got a para license
[Music]
okay maybe the act maybe the acts will
work better okay
chop chop chop chop chop come on ah ah
she's got skinnier legs give me
come on me yes Denise
now that the stupid swords yes it's big
it's beautiful I can't see I'm blinded
by its power huh I need a shield as well
fight me like a real man yeah no my
precious taste it you're making me angry
take stick don't get up don't ever get
up
don't dieter this is what you get
apologize
oh not like this ah what's that I had
legs all aligned I'm doing another level
let's see which one having not done what
is this arena I think we've done market
I think we've done ruins also Canyon is
the only new one okay I mean it is the
classic wonder what kind of damage you
can do with it let's try a gamer's it's
hammer time
don't hurt me I only have hammer oh it's
a little heavy he's trying to run damn
it he made it out of line nice you will
never walk you will never watch
oh no I unplugged guys sorry mate okay
sorry mate
my cable unplug yeah
oh yes yes this is a fine one
oh yes mmm nope not this one let's see
what this dish
nope but it's not that one either what
about oh yes no it's not this one either
okay oh let me find please I just want
get them to me
this will only hurt a lot beautifu well
I think that's enough for today
hope you guys enjoyed be nice and kind
to each other and smash like on this
video if you enjoyed the merch check out
merch you know where to find it and see
you gamers tomorrow remember keep it in
the video games well you haven't tried
to persuade me later citizen e after 50
million outros fetch down just down it's
still relevant
just down